good morning done a couple of warnings
about this video first if you find
cuteness offensive you should probably
leave now also if you are prone to squee
take the necessary precautions video is
about the tiniest thing doing this of
course because the world's smallest
chameleon was recently discovered in
Madagascar and it is very tiny and I'm
also thinking because the episode of
scishow that we did on tardigrades went
really really well anybody don't care
really maybe shove honey badger out of
an airlock into the vacuum of space and
see if he cares then tardigrade don't
care
dunk dunk but Berta greige this will guy
while being very very tiny is not the
smallest reptile that honor goes to the
Virgin Island dwarf gecko pictured here
full grown on a dime the Virgin Island
Wharf gecko does not however take the
prize for smallest vertebrate that
either goes to a frog or a fish shining
on which side of the controversy you're
on it makes sense that the smallest
vertebrate would be water-dwelling
because they do not have to deal with
the pressure of gravity as much because
they get to be underwater now I would
tell you the name of this frog but I
can't pronounce it here it is pictured
on a dime apparently that's the thing to
do when unless you're the world's
smallest snake in which case you're so
massive that you have to be pictured on
a court for people who aren't American
this is a dime it's our smallest coin
even though it's worth more than pennies
and nickels and this is a quarter so
that's how big those animals are even
smaller then that frog is a fish a fish
that we'd nerdfighters know a little bit
about but I did not know that it was the
smallest vertebrate the male anglerfish
so most biologists don't count it
because it relies on sexual parasitism
to survive but whatever I'm on the
anglerfish side of that debate I'm on
the angler for your side up in every
debate okay I'm willing to admit that so
far this hasn't been particularly cute
but we're gonna change that around by
now going to smallest warm-blooded
animals and the smallest warm-blooded
creature is the bee hummingbird and call
it a chick okay smallest mammal however
harder to determine by length the
smallest mammal is kittis hog-nosed bat
which i think is adorable
and by mass the Etruscan shrew is the
smallest mammal so I'm gonna go with the
Etruscan shrew because math seems like
the one you want to go with there and oh
my god is she cute there was however
once upon a time a smaller mammal the
long extinct bad to join it is down
Houten
a kind of shrew which I only mentioned
because of the van houten and finally
our last wild animal world's smallest
primate Madame Berthe Smouse Lima it
weighs just over an ounce and is so
pretty little sweet I'd aborted wittle
don't you want go jump top and then we
have a selection of domestic animal
duckie at 1.4 pounds the current
smallest dog Thumbelina a miniature
horse that turned out to be way more
mature than any other miniature horse at
just 17 inches tall which does not sound
healthy and we're finishing off on mr. P
bullish no mr. Peeples mr. Peeples is my
favorite animal of this video because it
led me to the Google search of cat in a
cup where I found so many catch in car
it's a cat nakum it's a cat and colorful
it's a cat nakum
oh yeah it's a get in the car I'll see
you on Tuesday
how did you say that you wanted in a wet
shirt oh well I can do that for you I
made I'm no edge design it's like my
face I'm doing like it's available now
for pre-order at dftba.com